we're so much more ready for everyone it
was so much more than soccer this time
there's so much more than what we did on
the field it was everything off the
field it was what this movement is about
normally just equal pay but just sort of
think women in general being valued you
know being appreciated being respected
in the way that we should I'm so excited
for what's to come not only for myself
but all the people on the team and for
the sport I just feel like this is one
of those incredible moments that are
very rare in history what is it that
you're hoping people take away from all
of this more than just the victory we're
talking about this movement that's
happening do you think this will
actually help push it a little bit
further I mean a men's team as we've
been able to accomplish this to work I
do think it will push it forward I think
that we've that the conversation needs
to not be about you know are we worth it
or equal pay you know revenue or TV
viewership and whatever we have all of
that which we've literally checked every
single box we're right there obviously
with the men and in some cases higher
and I think it's now time to move
forwards and how do we bring the women's
game to the next level what do we need
to do to push that forward whether
that's in leagues with FIFA supporting
the women's Federation's around the
world I think it's no surprise that when
Federation saw the world support their
women seems they do better we're the
perfect example of that
our support from the Federation is
unparalleled around the world and a
four-time world champion so just
speaking up for important issues that we
feel I'm so passionate about so it's
been great to ride this journey along
with Hampton and we hear you say you use
the phrase America's terms I'm going to
ask the question obviously this this
standoff with President Trump and Megan
has said you know I'm not alone on this
I might be the face of it did you give
us how the team and yourself included
feels in general about making a visit to
the White House yeah I don't want to
like necessarily speak for the entire
team obviously we all have our own
opinions and I'm sure that they'll get
shared eventually I've said my piece
I don't feel necessarily welcome there
and so I don't believe that I will be
individually attending I think you know
in the past we've all decided as a team
so we'll have to see that in the future
but there's a lot of things the
president Trump you know it's been a
place that I don't stand for
last question you know we have a lot to
talk about within the team like
literally it hasn't been 24 hours since
since we won this beautiful piece but we
have a lot to talk about and I'm sure
that anything that that we can continue
to braise and use our plot raise our
voice use their platform floor we will
do so thanks guys
it feels great we've been like 20 but
yeah we're happy back when you got that
second goal yesterday I guess that was
yesterday right feels like an eternity
ago doesn't it how did that feel when
that finally happened yeah I feel like
there was just some relief I feel if you
could take a breath but they weren't
giving us a lot of space the whole game
and I think trying to be able to kind of
break through and get it to nothing
clean it can't be a dangerous leap I
think we felt a lot of confidence after
that and you know who just kind of kept
giving it a hundred percent
more than becoming world champions you
guys have should have been champing this
cause of equal pay for women getting
this win do you feel like that helps
that cause as well yeah I mean let's
hope so oh do you how do you think it
will help I mean I don't know I think we
just kind of have this winning mentality
and I think it shows every time we fly
and I think we've had a lot of success
if we're just as deserving as any men's
player is do you think that that needs
to happen don't you
absolutely but anything else you want
people to know anything else USA no go
USA